this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by talk space manscaped and
hawthorne more on that later let's get
into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we
are over here in the night pants studios
i am ryan sickler ryan sickler on
all social media ryan sickler.com
and again thank you everyone who's
watching
subscribing commenting all of it i love
you for it i love doing this show
um it's a lot of fun to sit here and
listen to people
laugh about the the trouble they've been
in the trauma they've gone through
um i love getting the messages from you
guys about how much
it helps so it's helping me too there's
a lot of weird [ __ ] going on in the
world right now and
i appreciate you all out there uh make
sure you subscribe
to the youtube channel youtube.com r
sickler
uh we've got time codes for all the
stories and stuff in there there's also
a clips channel make sure you subscribe
to the clips channel the honeydew clips
channel
i'll promote that out there on social
media and the patreon right now we're
doing the honeydew with you all we got
over a thousand subscribers already and
if you sign up for a yearly subscription
you'll save over a month on the uh of
free episodes
so uh sign up for that and if you have a
story or someone you know has a story
that needs to be heard submit that at
honeydewpodcast
gmail.com not the other 40 places you
guys keep submitting them
but it'd be awesome if you could just
submit them to the honeydewpodcast
gmail.com so i had like a one place to
go look for them because there's a lot
of fantastic [ __ ] out there all right
also go subscribe to my facebook fan
page we got to get that thing up to 10
000
followers or else you can't promote more
facebook sucks
but go subscribe to the damn thing um
the honeydewpodcast.com that's the
website for the show that's where you
can get everything the merch the night
pants i want to tell you we got new
merch coming now we've got
brand new i don't know what this is
going to come out right before halloween
and we're pre-recording so i don't know
if they'll be out yet but i think they
will be
new night pants nation champion sweats
are coming
we've got a lot of new shirts we got a
lot of new [ __ ] coming so
uh i appreciate you all supporting night
pants nation out there the shorts
too i can't believe you guys wanted
shorts so they came out
uh the hoodies are the most comfortable
hoodie i've ever had my life
blah blah blah it's all good and the
honeydew strong shirts if you at
all proceeds of that go to santa monica
music center where i record here so if
you live in la
or anywhere actually now and you want to
take some online classes this is the
spot to do it
they've got local la musicians that'll
teach you your kids whatever take a
lesson with your kids so go to santa
monicamusic.com
use the code honeydew and they'll waive
the registration fee and give you a free
lesson
when you sign up for a package all right
that's the biz right there now i'm very
excited to have this guest here
uh we've been talking about this for a
little while a lot of you hit me up
about this
uh particular person and i'm very
excited to have her here the first time
on the honeydew ladies and gentlemen
kate kennedy y'all welcome to the
honeydew girl thanks for having me
thank you for being here i appreciate it
i have to have a sip of water i
appreciate you sitting through that
intro
no you're good that was a that was a
whole monologue that was a monologue
yeah
so we got to do we got to plug it up
here make sure everybody gets theirs in
uh and speaking of that please whatever
you'd like before we get started promote
everything yeah uh you can follow me on
twitter at the og kennedy i'm that
everywhere online you can go to the og
kennedy.com if you would like to join my
only fans
it's like five dollars um my best deal
ever and then i have a show coming up
in uh in long beach if you're in la i
have a show on halloween and the info
for that is on my instagram twitter
everywhere
five dollars a month for your only fans
that's what i that's what i charge for
my patreon everybody same thing it's a
great investment you should
double up today 10 bucks boom boom knock
it out
um well thank you again for being here
and um
i mean i find you fascinating i i've
thank you i find myself fascinating
you should i um i've gotten like
i don't i haven't met you yeah right no
have we met in passing or at a show or
nothing
so no i'm terrible at that sometimes bad
about it
but i've heard great things about you
from the josh's josh adam myers and josh
potter
oh both josh yeah both josh's yeah and
then
a lot of fans have hit me up saying
you'd be a great guest on here and i
know the ymh fans love you
and i love them so yeah they're the best
they actually are the bulk of my only
fan subscribers
you and josh potter when that episode
came out my
fans on there like doubled overnight and
then
mommies are the [ __ ] they're the best
like to this day i get messages they're
like i love you on ymh and like that's
why i subscribe
i'm like i don't really care about your
porn i just liked you and i'm like okay
great i'm like naked right there but
that's cool too
oh you're right when they suck it up by
their messaging
listen i'm looking past your butthole to
say i like you girl
um all right so i definitely want to
talk to you about this you're the first
porn star uh i gotta say josh potter's
the first
sex worker that's been on the show yeah
but you're the first porn
retired porn star tired now just being
very clear about that
that uh on the show and look i'll be
honest with you like
you have done the two jobs that are a
nightmare for me for my daughter
porn and stand-up like i don't want her
going into either of those
more probably stand up totally kidding
if you ever hear this stella totally
kidding porn more
i actually joke all the time that i
think i might be the only stand-up comic
who's ever told
their parents that they wanted to be a
comedian and they were like oh thank god
it's just clothes on we support you
that's great
like all right so i have a million
questions
um but before we get into how you got
started
how did you tell let's talk about how
you told your parents or did you
and um and what their response to all
that was
uh so i didn't because i'm a [ __ ]
coward um
and they ended up finding out somebody
sent them a link to my twitter
which is actually embarrassing because i
was already doing jokes on there at that
point so like not only did they see my
nudes they also saw like my dumb
twitter jokes i was saying i don't
really know which one i'm more
embarrassed about are your parents
together
yes they're still together they're still
together um my parents are both so
they're retired now
uh they live in colorado where i grew up
um my dad was an engineer my mom taught
school
so they're like not hollywood people at
all
like they don't they have no frame of
reality for that
um they were not stoked that i did porn
they didn't really get it
um we went to therapy together who was
more upset mom or dad
ah they were both i mean they're like
those kind of like
upper middle class white people that
they don't get upset
they just get quiet oh both of them are
the same
well i don't know why you would make
choices like that but okay
like that's the whole that's their level
of anger they're both like that they're
both exactly like that
and you went to therapy together for
three hours
three hours you had a three hour session
[Laughter]
it's an hour for each of you oh boy and
we could have gone on i
we could whose idea was it to go to
therapy and why
i think it was my mother's my mother
loves therapy she's
she's about therapy she was a therapist
for a while um
yeah she loves it so we went it actually
ended up being a pretty good experience
um
there they didn't come around to porn
like they're not
i get it they're parents and also you
just have to you kind of have to let
people be
where they're at um but what was it was
your mom's goal to find out why you're
doing porn or was it to bring you guys
closer together like what did she feel
was this was was it all about what your
decisions or
more about like okay we need to be a
better unit the three of us like what
was the
gist of all of it there was a lot of it
was a lot of that
initially when they first found out
actually
when they very first found out my mom
straight up thought i was like mentally
ill
like that could be the only reason i was
doing that they tried to send me to
sex addicts rehab in arizona it's
actually the same one harvey weinstein
went to
yeah look how that works this is the
first day so it cost fifty thousand
dollars
and how long are you there i think like
three weeks and they didn't read the
website long enough to realize that they
don't accept women
oh wait first of all that's fine they're
like we'll get you on a plane
you can be there tomorrow and i was like
oh my god i regret not going every day
that would have been the funniest joke
of all time just to get there and
be like no don't mean they don't accept
women i thought that was sexist to do
that is sexism or is this just a camp
for like the [ __ ] up
scumbag dudes i mean yeah maybe that's
why this is where you go when you get
harvey weinstein where you're like i'm
i'm going to the desert
to work out my demons but i'm actually
going to spawn tucson
like that's what it is also isn't it
funny that just 21 days is all it needs
you need to get get rape out of your
system that's all we can change in 21
days to make sure you're not going to
rape and manipulate women anymore 21
[ __ ] days the [ __ ] out of here with
that totally reformed member of society
50
000 what a [ __ ] racket yeah yeah
god it would have been hilarious if you
showed up though so funny i don't know
why it is that's a movie you should make
that goddamn sitcom
you go to sex rehab and you're the only
you're like yeah yeah that would be
funny
it would be oh my god it'd be hilarious
okay so i mean are dad's friends like
saying [ __ ] like are your mom's friends
saying [ __ ] do they get are they getting
like you know i don't think so um
it's never come up i mean i think they
would tell me because they would be mad
about that
um so it's your boss like cindy at the
grocery store said sometimes
she saw your three something okay i mean
i
i don't think it's that'd be so funny i
don't think it's ever come up
um even like it took most people even
though i went to high school that didn't
find out i did porn until i was like
already retired most of them found out
this year
which is crazy i didn't keep in touch
with a lot of people and i wasn't like
around like i
moved out a long time ago so i kind of
was just like not there i guess
well you're 26 you said yeah i'm 26. all
right so
you haven't you can graduate that long
ago no you haven't even had a 10-year
reunion yet no i don't think i'm gonna
be invited
would you go if you were though would
you go i
i don't i don't want to i might if they
invite me i might i just think it'd be
fun i went to catholic school
oh my god it'll be every dude talking to
you in the corner and nobody over here
yeah
kkk so exactly like high school so yeah
par for the course so okay
all right how do you get started how old
are you when you get started where do
you get started
are you in colorado like tell me
everything so i was
23 i was just out of college it was like
a year out of college
and i had applied to grad school and i
didn't get in
um i got like a i got a handwritten
letter back which feels
very weird from the university of
colorado that they took the time to hand
write my address
i still don't really get that but um i
didn't get into grad school i didn't
know what i wanted to do i was just
stuck i was in like a dead-end
relationship everything was shitty
and um yeah i was riding like a
secretary job and i hate it i worked at
an accounting firm i was
awful at it i was late all the time like
it was just i was miserable i
hated it and like i had like a whole
kind of breakdown where i was just like
i can't
do this for the rest of my life like
this is not i don't know what i want to
do but it's not this
and i ended up getting an offer from
through a friend of a friend who knew
these people had gone to portland and uh
stayed with them and just hung out they
were like family friends of hers that
ran
this really intense bdsm porn studio
up in portland and a few months later
they emailed me and were like hey
uh we need a new marketing person and
one of my degrees is in advertising and
like social media management
and uh do you want a job in the adult
industry would you like to come work for
us so i started behind the scenes and i
worked as a pa
and a marketing manager for this company
yeah what's an aggressive bdsm
uh online it's online
yeah it's online so i mean we would
shoot like three to four movies a week
um and then i would work in the office
you like making sure that they all went
out to like our different like the
people that promote them and stuff
but what's the content like oh the girls
in the stockades yeah
like that like so we had it was due to
cages i've seen shitlong cages
those cages it was it was honestly like
the funnest job ever because i just got
to like try
like traipse around the woods in like
rural worlds oh you're out in the woods
oh yeah we're out
in my mind you're in like a studio or a
warehouse we're in we shot in a garage
in like rural oregon like the creepiest
and like i'm wearing like cargo pants
like doc martens like baseball cap every
day and i'm just building because we
have these these
kits of like different lengths of pipe
and wood it was like grown up
[ __ ] up tinker toys okay and we would
build these huge rigs and like
lock hot girls into them and just it was
so fun i loved it
and these girls will come out to the
woods and do this and [ __ ] yeah
and so how big's the crew like how many
people are watching these two people
do this uh it was me the director slash
handler and the camera ladies it was
three of us
camera lady yeah it was actually his
wife the guy that did it yeah
so lovely people i love them
so much that has to be a successful
marriage
for you to tell your wife to film me
[ __ ] these chicks in
way [ __ ] up ways she must love his a
he must love her too
they had the cutest little relationship
they had what is that
like it's [ __ ] everywhere
what is their sex life like you think
you think it's like crazy or is it like
way
subdued no i know what it's like and
it's crazy yeah it's real crazy
um but i like that kind of crazy stuff
so i started when i started performing i
started shooting for them because they
had said like you know
if you ever want to shoot for us like
well we'd be happy to book you
and have you do a scene and i did it for
behind the scenes for like six months
before i started shooting for them
because i wanted to make sure
and i was like all right my resume's
already shot the hell just
dive in and do this so then i started
shooting scenes for them that's all
right so hold on let's
start there for a second because you're
not just going into some
regular porn scene then if you're going
into porn you're jumping right into this
there's no progression to this you're
going from
you're jumping right to z basically wow
okay so how old are you when you first
do this uh
i was 23 when i shot my first scene
and i'm assuming it's with her husband
then yeah so we didn't actually
so they don't always do sex on those
sites like he doesn't actually it's
mostly toys and stuff
um because it's more focused on the bdsm
than
sex um so the first one i did was like
rope bondage
so i got all tied up and i like hung
upside down by my ankles it was so fun
in the woods uh this was in the studio
they do stuff in the woods though i
remember they buried a couple of girls
like up to their next one
they did like a mock crucifixion holy
[ __ ]
it was fun it was fun it was so fun i
mean imagine that you get to come
up with like four or five ideas for like
b-list horror movies
every single week and then just make
them happen
like that's really and we would get to
sit there and be like let's do this this
is weird like for thanksgiving one year
we smashed a pumpkin pie into this
girl's face and made this other girl
lick it off
it was so fun yeah it actually does
sound hot it was
yeah did you ever have a park ranger
roll up like what the [ __ ] are you all
doing back here man got girls buried up
through their necks and [ __ ]
actually this school bus dropped the
kids from the local school
right at the end of there because it's
very rural at the end of their driveway
so every day between 3 and 3 30 we'd
have to stop shooting because they can't
have the girls screaming when there's
kids walking home from school
oh my god
somebody would like come upstairs big
bus is here bus is here
we don't have to like cut
okay so your first scene is
tied up and hanging upside like it's not
even a missionary [ __ ] scene
hanging upside down my ankle seven and a
half minutes i was like the longest
person to hold that which i was quite
proud of
you got the record the girl a week
before can only do like three minutes
or six [ __ ] yeah
show you how it's done oh my god
and then what he just tortures you while
you're up there or you're just hanging
no i mean there's there's the slapping
and the canes and the
whips and chains and all that [ __ ] so
yeah i know it was fun i i liked that
kind of stuff
um i'm obviously a person i think that's
like attracted to like extreme
sensation or things like adrenaline so i
really enjoyed that and it was fun
that's the one i got waterboarded for
too
oh all right we're gonna come back to
that in a second where does that come
from
um you know i don't know like i was
fascinated
with it when i was little like even
before i understood what like sex was
like i i'm interested in the ways you
can like push your body to like endure
different things and like it is it's a
huge adrenaline rush
um so yeah i had just i had been into it
in like my personal life before like we
started doing this like
to the point where i went to conventions
and like classes and
done classes yeah what do you mean
classes and dungeons i used to like help
teach
classes about bdsm and like how to do
these different things
and even before you started yeah that
was how i knew those people was i just
socially in like denver when i was
living there after school um
was would go to this it was it it's a
very similar vibe
like a comedy club it's the same people
week after week and they go to play
um but we would do classes on like how
to do different techniques i had done a
little bit of like
rope bondage modeling like as a demo
where they're showing
how to tie you up and stuff so i was
already in that world
um but yeah i had just been i'd been
fascinated with forever and i
started getting involved in it like in
college and then a little after and
it turned into a job so that whole like
i've had um when i first moved here way
back
the first time i would go to these i
worked at a hotel and this guy will come
in all the time with these two
um escorts every night they'll be
and they would be having so much fun
we're like what do you do dude
and at the time he was like this
hollywood bad boy the lapd hated him
because he would rent mansions in the
hills and he would throw sex parties
and he was like you guys should all come
and
i didn't really know what i was in
but i didn't know what i was getting
into i didn't know if that meant we were
[ __ ] people
or what it meant and we get there and
what it was was uh it was very
i have to say like very elegant and well
done
um there was a big ass bouncer with a
velvet rope in front of like each room
and in this room it would be two girls
and this room a guy and a girl are
[ __ ] in this room there's a threesome
you know that sort of thing where you
could like an eyes wide shut sort of
party where you could watch
oh that's fancy mingle with other people
and drink and party or do
you know drugs whatever um so i'd always
seen that and then we would he would
invite us to the club and he'd always
get away with
naked girls dancing on the bars and [ __ ]
in the clubs you never got shut down
um but so i've always been fascinated by
like that that i've had
guests come on and talk about um working
at swingers clubs
and things like that too i did some
modeling at swingers clubs uh
what does that mean modeling like uh
like for different like fetish like
accessories
because there's people that will sell
them like they make them it's almost
like an etsy thing
and so like sometimes they would hire
like hot girls to come hang out at the
party and like wear
whatever and then people would ask you
about it there'd be like a table you
could like buy
the decorative nipple clamps or [ __ ]
whatever it was
but see now it's so like back when i
went i used to go to the block in
baltimore which is
you just do not want to [ __ ] go there
it's all seedy dirty [ __ ]
you know and now there's like this level
of
of class and elegance to this stuff like
there's a there's a store i saw at the
century city mall
um that's that's uh bondage and b but
it's like high-end like a victoria's
secret store for it i can't remember the
name of it but
um i was like okay they're trying to
normalize it i go how many how many moms
are coming by here with their kids like
we we get it we get a handful
like i listen to the audiobook of 50
shades of grey
let me add it that's exactly what it is
that's exactly what it is
it's that like i don't want to i don't
want it to look like
cd warehouse [ __ ] but i'll still do it i
just want it to be in a classier
way yeah i like the cd warehouse this
was in a cd warehouse uh
actually the swingers club in denver
doubles during the day as an orphaned
squirrel rehabilitation center
you can't make this [ __ ] up oh you can't
wait
they have like the swinging slip but
right outside is there a pages
squirrels and like incubators
there's certain parts you can't be too
loud because there's baby squirrels oh
my god
oh my god imagine the health inspection
at a place seriously
yeah or even being there at night like
i'm gonna go [ __ ] your wife over here by
these babies
baby squirrels yeah um all right so your
first scene is tied upside down
seven minutes rope bondage chains all
that they
shoot it yeah and then it goes up online
yeah
and do you watch it do you oh yeah like
stand up i can't i hate watching myself
but
you have to do it i hate watching myself
do stand up i like watching myself do
podcasts i don't really watch my porn
anymore
i watched my first i i watch anything
like that that i do with
like a very critical eye i think
everyone does but like a lot of times
i'll watch it to be like oh i need to do
this better
so when i was first starting porn and i
was like oh i need to get better at this
i would watch and be like oh
it looks weird when you make that face
or like oh don't do this
or like arch your [ __ ] back arch your
[ __ ] back was like a big one for me
yeah i could not do it and it looks
really bad and porn if you don't
um but yeah so i don't really i watched
that first one i was so excited because
it was
like the first one you know um so
when was there penetration in that video
the very first one
i don't think so so when was your first
actual sex scene then with a guy
um it was and was it that guy
no it was not it was for that company
but it was we had a male
talent that we would hire um and i got
[ __ ] in a wheelchair actually it was
supposed to be like a mental patient
and like a straight jacket on
and they did scenarios i was backwards
in the wheelchair
right so like i was facing yeah that way
okay and they didn't
i'm like tied to the chair and they
didn't bolt the chair down
so the whole time he's [ __ ] me i'm
just so worried this chair is gonna tip
forward and i'm just gonna eat it
on this stage that my fear in that scene
is very real but it's not
it's not because of nothing and then i
brought it up afterwards i was like you
didn't bolt the chair down and the
director goes yeah if it was anyone else
i probably would have but with you i
figured it would be better this way i
was like you're right but thanks for the
drama
like and what was that like it was fun
yeah yeah it was fun i i loved when i
first got into it it was really really
great
i uh i had so much fun and i loved doing
it porn is cool because like you get to
bang people but you don't have to go
through the whole like
so where are you from what's your family
like you don't have to talk to them very
much first
how much of a heads up do you get for
who
the guy or girl or whatever is gonna be
when you're shooting
uh it really depends on like the company
and just the booking like sometimes
especially like living in la i would do
a lot of last-minute stuff so
there's times like i didn't know who i
was working with until i got there for
real
have you ever walked out been like no
i'm not gonna work with this guy or that
person or um
yeah i have actually there's been a
couple you have a no list so generally
speaking they won't book you with
if you're like i don't like that you
should know trade clause this is your no
trade yes
this is my no yeah i'm not going to play
for these teams exactly
exactly yeah
and i had a long one too like there was
a lot of people where i was just like
because other women are telling you
don't work with these guys or other
people or like these aren't safe or what
is the what is the reason
some of that that's a big reason why
people do it um a lot of the times for
me it would just be that i would see
people like because you see each other
socially there's like events and stuff
important and like there would be people
where i'd just be like
no no don't come anywhere near me like i
don't
like i have no attraction to you
whatsoever like anything we shoot is
gonna suck
um or just people like if people are
like popping off being crazy on social
media because
it's kind of the same as like being on a
show with somebody
like you don't necessarily want to be
associated with this person that's
going out here and [ __ ] up um so that
was always kind of my
mindset with it but i know there's
people that have like nobody on their no
list and then people have
miles long ones so yeah so you've gotten
there and said no
and left yeah mm-hmm and what happens
then
um i mean i would just i think the one
time there was only like one time i
called my agent
and was like no and it was because they
i wasn't comfortable working with this
girl like her test was weird
and i was in i had i was living in l.a
hiv tests
yeah because we use we use a centralized
system for all of our testing it's
called pass
and it's a private network that has if
you're in it you can look up anyone
you're working with by their legal name
and you can see all of their test
results for like going back
and um this girl had a test but it
wasn't from one of the like accredited
labs where it was in the system it was
like from kaiser
yeah no yeah exactly yeah and i
just looked at him i was like i can't
like i can't work with this person
like even if i wanted to or was
comfortable with it i can't
like my agent would kill me so i just
called my agent i explained the
situation and i went home
i was like this is not okay the guy
later called me and apologized actually
which is cool
so this is what trips me out excuse me
because you said you were waterboarded
for a scene so i know you're down to do
some [ __ ] so
what what turned you off to that
they asked me if i wanted to do it they
had been wanting to do a waterboarding
scene
for ages it was the same company i was
working at and uh
legit you got waterboarded yeah i did
while having sex
uh wow uh hitachi was on me so i had
like a vibrator on my [ __ ] yeah
yeah the big wand one yeah yeah and and
what what and
waterboarding like do you feel like
you're drowning it's a terrible way to
get information from tourists
i would tell everybody like i couldn't
remember my name afterwards they're like
doing the exit interview and they're
like so how is that i was like
for real oh yeah dude it [ __ ] with your
mind that much i mean
well like i also came really hard yeah
that too so like but they
yeah because they're pouring it and i
mean we cut it together right so like i
could still
it was safe i wouldn't have done it with
anyone else i'd known these people and
trusted them
but like it's dark you can't breathe
because the cloth is over so if you try
to breathe you're just breathing in
water
like it's it's a really intense
experience
and like how long are they keeping it on
your face before they pull it up or are
you doing that
uh they would like they would cut for a
second and pull it up like every like 30
seconds or so that's a long time yeah
it's a long time
yeah it was it was crazy and that got
you off oh yeah
it was awesome it was so awesome
i've never met anybody
okay all right so um
what was your first so here you gave me
a list of stuff here so
waterboarder for sure um okay tell me
about this new york story because you
said you also worked as an escort before
right
yeah so when i first what was first
escort or porn porn okay
so i moved to la after like a year
working in portland um because i started
i'd gone to like avn
and got an agent and like started to
come down and shoot for more mainstream
companies and it was going well so i was
like well
i'll pack it up and move down to la and
uh
so i had been doing that for a while and
la's
really [ __ ] expensive especially when
you're trying to get your career off the
ground and so i
had started out squirting and i it was
that very kind of like high-end
like it was a lot of like news anchors
and celebrities like it was
it was a nice kind of thing i never had
an issue i
like some girls in porn look down on
that most of them do it anyways
i have no idea what's the difference
exactly
i don't [ __ ] know um did you work for
a company like is there a company that
yeah that
um find your clients and screens them
and knows them like i never yeah i was
never put in any position where
anyone wasn't like but theoretically if
you wanted to you could just have
three people two people mm-hmm regulars
yeah
i mean hell what's the difference in
dating two people that's mostly what it
was honestly i mostly just saw the same
people it was almost kind of like a
sugar daddy situation
um but i had been doing it for a while
and doing pretty well and so when you're
doing that what they do is they go on
tours where you go to like new york
for two weeks and you stay at a fancy
hotel and you see
clients in new york so that was what the
idea was for them i see
right so and you on these tours you make
between twenty and thirty thousand
dollars okay so that's what i was going
to ask you that's more lucrative than
porn it's
enormously i mean we talked about porn
honestly being like the equivalent i
hear about all the time like open mic
pay and [ __ ] like what these comedy
clubs are still throwing at you 50 bucks
a couple hundred dollars and [ __ ] like
that for porn
i didn't know how much openers made like
on the road until
a few months ago and then someone told
me and i was like say what
i've been paid less than that for a
porno like you got how much
like oh [ __ ] i'm just gonna stick with
this you're just opening
it's not that much more though yeah
that's the problem yeah pouring out your
soul and your body
for [ __ ] nothing in these two uh
professions that's sure at least in porn
it's just your body
yeah um but uh yeah so i uh
i went to new york it was the first time
i'd ever been to new york and uh
i had been kind of talking to this guy
like totally separate from it
and um we hung out we went to dinner and
i
i fell in love a little bit i like met
this great boy and i wanted to restart
like
this guy was nothing he had nothing to
deserve
nothing no nothing just like i'm coming
to new york
yeah we had been like talking online and
then i was i said i'm coming to new york
and he told me afterwards he's like yeah
i hollered at my roommate he's like i'm
gonna ask the hot girl on a date
i'm gonna ask her on a date and uh we
just hit it off and
i had to call my booking agent and be
like hey i'm sorry i quit i'm gonna go
spend two weeks in new york like making
out with this pretty boy
in museums and in central park and
everywhere else goodbye sorry thank you
and so
and they were surprisingly really cool
with that
because i mean they were losing too they
got like 25 so they also were losing
like almost 10 grand i can't believe
they were okay with this
yeah but yeah they're like go have fun
so i spent two weeks in new york like
going to broadway shows and dancing in
speakeasies and drinking red wine and
having great sex and taking bubble baths
it was awesome
and i lost thirty thousand dollars it
cost me thirty thousand dollars
thirty [ __ ] thousands i don't regret
it i do sometimes
sometimes when my bank account gets low
i regret that but you know
it was worth it it was a fun adventure
and then that then you never went back
to that again
um yeah i know after that i quit i
actually quit escorting because it was
i've never dated the whole time i was in
porn
um i've been single since i was like 22
23.
um there was there ever a guy important
that you were like i want to work with
you again and again
like yeah you're comfortable with them
or whatever there's
a lot of i have like guy friends in porn
like to this day where i'll shoot
content with um
like i'm very close with james dean and
so he'll come over and we shoot content
like every other month or whatever
um just because we're genuinely friends
but there was never anyone a lot of the
guys that i worked with were older and
married
um married that's all these trips
married yeah
um and their wife some of their wives
are porn stars too so a lot of them yeah
sex is not a thing for people in that
industry
that like you can legit be friends with
a guy and just [ __ ] them and be like
thanks see you later yeah
absolutely yeah which i really like
because the whole like intricacies
surrounding like
intimacy and dating and being with some
those
just confuse me i don't like that i'm
very straightforward like i have no game
i joke about this all the time i have no
[ __ ] game my whole game is like
hey uh would you like to have sex with
me that would be cool
that's it that's my whole setup that's
the whole pitch
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor talk space now
it's not easy to prioritize yourself
when there's a lot on your plate but
investing in your mental health has
long-term benefits and with talk space
it can actually be affordable you know
i'm a big believer in therapy all kinds
of therapy
talking it out talking to people getting
help when you need to
it's a very difficult time to do that
right now especially in person
uh and unlike in person therapy sessions
talk space gives you 24 7
access to your online therapy room you
can send unlimited messages to your
dedicated therapist and they'll
respond daily five days a week and best
of all an entire month
on talk space cost about the same amount
as a single
in-person session and now talkspace
covers 40 million people for online
therapy through their insurance or
employer all right talk the talkspace
network is composed of thousands of
licensed therapists who have experienced
in over 40 specialties including but not
limited to treating depression
anxiety substance abuse trauma
relationship issues food and eating
and much more talk space is secure and
private
using the latest encryption technology
to store client information
the bottom line is that we all need
someone to talk to and talkspace wants
to give you the support you deserve
at a price you can afford as a listener
of this podcast you get 100
off your first month on talkspace to
match with your perfect therapist you
want to go to talkspace.com
or download the app and make sure you
use the code honeydew
to get that 100 off your first month and
show your support for the show
again that's talkspace.com code honeydew
our next sponsor is hawthorne uh and
i've been thinking about making some
personal changes lately and i i wanted
to start by improving my self-care
routine okay the problem was i had no
idea where to start
and then i found hawthorne hawthorne is
a premium tailored personal care brand
that's making it easy for guys
to feel and smell your best so you start
with their quiz and then they ask you
things like
uh what's your favorite drink how do you
like to spend a night out do you smoke
and then they factor your answers
into your results okay it was actually
uh
really easy it was quick it was fun it
was interesting i hadn't been asked
questions like that before
um and i got so many great products i
got uh two types of cologne i got
bar soap i got body wash uh deodorant
i mean between my stepson and ash
everybody's taking all these hawthorne
products we're all on them right now so
if you want to upgrade your self-care
routine hawthorne's a fun and convenient
way to get super high quality products
tailored specifically for your needs
hawthorne even takes the risk out of it
by giving you free shipping on your
order and your returns and if you don't
like your products
they'll even retailer them for you based
on your feedback now do what i did take
hawthorne's quiz today
and get started on your personalized
self-care routine by going to
hawthorne.co
okay that's hawthorne.co use the code
honeydew look if you're looking to
up your game ladies if you're looking
for something for your man
moms if you're looking for something for
your teenage sons whatever
hawthorne is great okay that's hawthorne
h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot co promo code honeydew one more time
hawthorne.co
promo code honeydew our next sponsor is
manscape now listen up fellas because
today we have a new manscaped product
alert manscape just released the weed
whacker it's a nose and ear hair trimmer
all right you take a look in the mirror
i guarantee you'll see some hair
sticking out of those holes it's time to
keep your ear and nose hair
looking as nice as your clean shaving
pubes all right
uh i always trim my nose hairs i'm big
on getting those nose hairs
and then they get out and i'm like man
you don't want to look like some you've
seen those people on tv you're like does
anybody love you dude you got hair
coming out of your nose it's all over
your eyebrows out of your ears like
are you a wolf man what's your problem
manscape is forever changing the
grooming game with their weed whacker
this nose and ear hair trimmer provides
proprietary skin safe technology
which helps prevent nicks snags and tugs
in those delicate little holes it's
intelligently contoured design enhances
the trimming experience
and it's waterproof which makes for easy
operation and cleaning
the only nose hair trimmer on the market
with a powerful
and rechargeable lithium ion battery
that lasts for up to 90 minutes of use
manscaped is making whacking your weeds
a time to look forward to delivering
maximum confidence while providing
hygiene
yes you will get a replaceable blade
every three months to keep your weed
whacking time
clean and enjoyable look fellas 79
percent of partners polled admitted that
long nose hairs is a major turn off it's
time to upgrade your manscape routine
with the weed whacker
thank you manscape for keeping our pubes
trimmed and our hairs and our holes
looking nice
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code honeydew at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
make sure you're using
the code honeydew what are you waiting
for go whack your weeds
now let's get back to the do so what is
it i want to ask you personal questions
then
what is it like when you do meet someone
you really like
what is intimacy like for you then do
you slow play it then
do you dial it back then do you ramp it
up um
does it feel different does it feel
special how do they
feel you know i mean this one uh in new
york was
that was the first time i'd like felt
like that about someone really like in
my
adult life probably and it was really
special and that kind of
honestly that was the thing that started
gears turning in my head of like
okay even if it's not with this person
like
i am getting older i'm getting through
my 20s i want to
have a boyfriend at some point like that
would be nice and like i want to i
the best sex you'll ever have is really
enthusiastic sex with someone you really
like
amen that's the best right and so i
realized that i was like okay like i
learned something about myself i also
learned that like i can't date anyone
while i'm doing porn
um because even when i came back to l.a
after being with him in new york
i it was like torture to try to go to
work i didn't want to have sex with
anyone else
yeah um and i was just like okay i guess
was it because it was a you felt a
connection to him or you knew it would
be a step
down or what was the reason ah it was
kind of both
i yeah i felt like a connection to him i
just didn't you know when you have that
like intimacy you don't want to
really get it anywhere else and i had
never experienced that before um
so that was like a big learning process
for me that whole trip and then coming
back and like it really
for months i i really had some like
self-growth going on where i was trying
to figure out like what i wanted to do
um how was did you were you honest with
him about what you did and
oh yeah yeah totally he knew he knew
that i did and he's like very sex work
positive which was really cool like i
never
felt like shamed or anything about it we
were always really open with each other
so it was cool
like of all the people that like learn
that lesson with he was a really good
one
so we're still good friends yeah good
mm-hmm yeah
so all right i have more questions for
you um
worst sex worst porn experience worst
and then i want to hear best
yeah uh okay worst was
this one it was a new room massage scene
so that's where they take like the gel
and they pour it all over your body
yeah it's a gel so like you can get this
like
they they do this as a legit massage
they do it like the bunny ranch and
stuff and when you go get it done they
heat the gel up so it's warm
and it but when it's warm it turns white
and you can't pour white go well over
people that's for the end of the porn
so like when we do it has to be cold
and it's like thick and viscous and it
dries to like the consistency of post-it
note glue
ew yeah is it like the um
ultrasound [ __ ] they squirt on you you
know when they're gonna do that
like that thick like slime almost yes
yeah
it's a little more liquidy and it's just
what it just looks great on camera is
that what it is
it looks really listening yeah your
body's covered and you're like rubbing
his body you can slide right the [ __ ]
off somebody like the duke boys across
the hood of the general league
it's really scary like they make you do
it on like a pool raft it's like a
floaty
inflatable raft and like yeah you can
until it once it dries then it's just
like
like rip but when it's slick yeah you
can slide right off of that thing
um and it was me and this guy who i've
been very good friends with for years
like in the industry
so he and i are tight like we're homies
right so we get set and we're giving
each other [ __ ] and having a really good
time and there's this
other girl that's there who we don't
know and she
shows up with just i don't have ever
seen somebody have a worse attitude
about anything
i mean she shows up and is just like
nose in the air like i don't
and then she didn't know what we were
doing i guess her agent didn't give her
was it a threesome scene is that what
you're about to do a threesome but she
didn't know about the nuru part
and so the director who's this like
super patient really nice guy
good friend of mine too like he's
explaining it to her and he's going
through and she's ugh
that's just that's so gross i just i
don't even know if i can do this it's
disgusting i can't do it
and he looks and goes well can you let
us know now because we'll replace you
but like
do or die and uh she continues just the
worst
attitude the whole time and then her
[ __ ] smells like a sewer
i'm like oh i've been waiting for this
oh dude both my my buddy and i are just
like the whole time
and you can't stop no i mean like we're
okay every time she would leave the room
the director would look at us and just
go
i've never he you can't say hey can we
have her rinse off or do something over
here
no no yeah
like i mean there's yeah it was just it
was so
that's the thing about porn that a
friend of mine told me one time he's
like you know
he did a camera shoot one time and he
goes here's the thing about porn that
you do
it looks great you know it looks great
this guy he was on a scene where it was
a
threesome and they were doing anal and
he goes but what you don't
see is what it smells like on the set
and i
was like oh yeah he's like you don't see
you don't smell the smells
and that includes people's hygiene and
[ __ ] like
[ __ ] that's gross it's so gross and yeah
there's a lot of people in horn that
don't
necessarily have the best hygiene and
it's just
i mean it's nausea inducing like it
makes me gag
you've been like thinking about it like
that would be where i would say i'm not
working with this person
yeah she went on my no list right after
that and then she was like trying to be
a rapper which was
awesome it was so funny and like
and now she's pregnant which is even
like
dude okay here's the thing though like
it's men and women experience certain
things differently because like as a
chick
finding out that a chicky banged is
pregnant is just hilarious it's not
scary at all
it's so funny um but uh
yeah she was oh man that was like the
worst that one sucked
it was just a long day we earned our
money that day
how long was as an average shoot hour
two hours
it depends i mean most of the time like
a good director like that you can get in
and out in like two to four hours
in and out and how many you come and you
go um
like a two well like onset usually for a
full day probably like four hours with a
good director like that because you're
in here and makeup for like an hour hour
and a half
and then you have to do all the dialogue
the sex only takes like maybe
20 to 30 minutes oh that's it the sex is
the shortest part the dialogue takes
[ __ ] forever nobody knows their lines
it's it's a nightmare like so yeah the
sex itself is
is the last thing you shoot and it's
usually the easiest part of the day
um but i've been on sets for like 14
hours before
jesus yeah um best
best experience um i did
raw with manuel ferreira um raw
it's a series he does where it's like
kind of like hotel room hookup so it's
like really casual it's just him and
he's just like
very good-looking french guy with like
an enormous dick and like
he's very he's one male performer of the
year like i think more almost more than
anyone else
like he's won it six or seven he's the
best at sex he has like
seven trophies to prove it like he's
easy
oh my god and he's like french so he
whispers these like dirty things in here
but i can't really understand him i just
know that it's i'm really
doing it i'm like yeah do whatever you
want to me
um what do you look like uh he's tall
he's
like older now he's kind of related like
dark hair just
like a generally handsome looking dude
but older
older yeah i think he's he's in his 40s
i think yeah so
most of the the vast majority of people
i worked with in porn were like
at least 10 years older than me minimum
minimum i look young
he's 20 plus years older yeah so i mean
steve holmes is i think
60 and i worked with him several times
really yeah
i did a bunch of horny grandpa porn for
a while did you really
i was really young so i would just
always get cast as that and like
and that never turned you off to be the
guy that old no not really
especially like something like steve is
so lovely and fun and and funny and
cool to hang out with that you're just
because it is more of like
a good day on a porn set should be like
just a bunch of friends like hanging out
and shooting the [ __ ] and having a good
time
like it doesn't necessarily have to have
that like oh i have to have you now
passion
right yeah and it's also the way it shot
is really fun because it's just you him
in the camera so there's nothing else
and like now that i shoot my own content
that's how i shoot it too where it's
just
oh so there's no not even a camera
person in there no i shoot all my own
stuff
just on my camera i might do two angles
but then it's just actual like real
sex where you're not cause important
like you said it looks good you're
opening up
those are not natural positions it
doesn't feel good
the vast majority of porn does not feel
like guys that always put their hand
back like this so you can still see
everything
like nobody [ __ ] like this yeah you're
like dislocating your head
like this yeah it's no
it's not even a good move it
doesn't even look right you look tired
right
yeah because they don't want to be
because they they shoot around the guys
all the time it reminds me of when uh
the nfl players or athletes get tired
you know they're tired when they start
putting their hands on their knees
i see these guys i'm like this poor
[ __ ] here he's had to do two
scenes today
okay french guy you said has an enormous
dick which leads me to my is what's the
biggest
dick you've had to handle on camera
like 12 13 engines
yeah that's like my [ __ ] four dude
it's i was watching it
so like i was shooting content it was
being dread
and i he had it on the ipad so i could
see it and i could see it like going in
my ass
and i had took it in your hand and i had
this moment where i was like this is
what people feel like watching the
footage of their own colonoscopy
like i don't want to know this about
myself so i just like looked away
you took 12 did you enjoy it oh yeah it
was really fun
it was fun we got pizza afterwards pizza
we listened to steely dan we both really
like stealing dan
that's absurd i can't even
you're right you can't [ __ ] make that
[ __ ] up
you're listening to reeling in the years
after that
holy [ __ ] that is unbelievable
um okay what's something you did
but you won't do again like important
for me skydiving
i went here yeah i did it i ain't doing
that [ __ ] again i wouldn't go skydiving
you're going to have to be adrenaline
junkie though so that's what how many
i've been or i've been asked a few times
to go um no you're not missing anything
no my dad my sister go a lot actually
they like enjoy it really yeah so you're
all a bit of adrenaline junkies it
sounds like oh yeah
we definitely are for sure my family's
weird so what is it you wouldn't do
again
um because you've definitely done some
[ __ ]
hung upside down yeah
i've done i did a gang bang i've done
a gang how many guys uh five there's
five guys in a gang bang
yeah is that official yes oh i didn't
realize that what so what's
when you do ten then what are these
girls that are doing it's a silly
gangbang it just has to have at least
five
minimums yeah so typically they shoot
him with five because then it's
obviously cheaper you're saving money on
not having extra talent so it's just a
foursome then prior to that yeah it
doesn't count
man you can [ __ ] three guys and it's not
a gang bang it doesn't count
that's a shame i know i think after
threesome it should be a gangster
close but no cigarettes but five is
official gang five is official
you took five guys yes the [ __ ] is that
like is that a lot of work i feel like
it's a lot of work for you
it was last minute i was it was like 7
30 in the morning i got a call from my
agent he like hey can you be downtown
in an hour to shoot this for king for
like an anal gangbang
anal gang and i was like i think it's
how much money i was like i'll be there
i'll be there so they got up and got
ready and
had to run down and go and then the
thing was i had tickets actually to go
see goddamn comedy jam at the roxy
and
this is your morning up this is my
morning up
and so i got just that and i was like
you know hey guys um i i have a heart
out today
um i'm sure we'll be done in time but
then we're all hanging out and they're
like oh what is it you know and i was
like oh i'm going to see it was jim
jeffries was doing it
the rock scene was like i'm going to see
jim jeffries tonight the roxy and
all the guys were like wait this sounds
really fun can we can we come so one of
the guys from my gang bang came with me
are you for real he's like doing
anything so yeah we went and then we all
went to the rainbow afterwards it was
really fun
yeah that's a porn star spot anyway the
rainbow from back in the day
yeah it is my actually my age used to
work there was a waitress back in like
the 80s yeah
um what is that like five [ __ ] guys
all in the butt yeah great i had oh i
said
right yeah but it was great um
but see i've always heard about porn or
anal in porn that it's not about what
you ate today
it's about what you ate yesterday yeah
so how are you getting a last-minute
call
without knowing you know what i mean i
feel like a five dicks
up the ass is a i need a night of prep
you know what i mean
i have a pretty talented [ __ ]
good
but that like i'll admit i have some
good qualities oh my god
yeah you just rinse out and then uh you
take an imodium actually because it like
stops your system
so then you're and i was good yeah i've
never had enough that's the same
podium and rinse rinse out yeah and then
just eat lightly through the day if you
get
noticed like i usually stop eating at
like seven o'clock the night before
but it's never been i some people
struggle with it more i've never had an
issue with it i
like anal i like anal sex my personal
life okay like let me ask you this then
were there things in your how old were
you when you lost your virginity
17 okay were there things in your
personal life that you hadn't done yet
that you first did in porn
like had you had anal yet before you did
porn yeah oh yeah yeah
for sure threesomes before you did porn
yep
so yeah bought what about the bondage
stuff you said yeah the bondage stuff i
was
pretty yeah out there
yeah and and comfortable early on pretty
much
so well then your transition kind of was
your regular personal life
in getting into the yeah stuff if
anything like the porn i started doing
especially when i moved to la and was
doing mainstream stuff was way less
extreme
than what i was doing before so it was
easy they'd get to like i'd get sent
they'd be like can you do this position
i'd be like yeah
that's nothing i've hung upside down by
my ankles this is easy
yeah um yeah so no it was i mean
yeah it just i'd already done all of
that so it was
there was is there anything you did in
porn for the first time in your sex life
that you had i mean other than being
waterboarded and chilling yeah
right uh oh i had never fisted anybody
you fisted someone yes i actually won an
award for it this year
what a whirl what is it the golden fist
that's a better
a girl or a guy uh it was a girl um and
she was actually one of my very good
friends at the time and we worked
together for
kink and i fisted her [ __ ] and i was
so
i was so nervous the whole time because
thinking [ __ ]
no nope straight up in there i mean
like how the oh my god and i have little
arms
but like that's not little yeah for an
[ __ ] for an [ __ ]
you put your whole arm of her butt i was
so nervous too i was like
i would be too yeah yeah okay and i'm
normally never like that but at that i
was
oh my god and she was into it yeah have
you ever been fisted
um yes
in your butt i can fist my own butt i
don't ever
i don't let anyone else do it i can do
it to myself you don't laugh
no yeah how do you practice that uh okay
so the way i found out i could do it i
was
uh in the bath and i was a little stoned
and
i was like playing with my butthole and
i was like i wonder
i just wonder so i like grabbed some
lube
and i started doing it and it went in
and i was so excited that i i lived with
my boyfriend at the time this was way
before i had a point
i jumped out of the tub and my fist was
still in my [ __ ]
like man i
this is the most outrageous [ __ ] i've
ever heard and he's like you're getting
the carpet all wet
[Laughter]
and your fist is up your butt i did not
care no enthusiasm for this whatsoever
yeah but is that something you get off
on like is that something you put into
your personal sex life
like you can fist my butthole i think i
have a weird like
disparity dichotomy i'm not sure the
word um between like
that kind of sex and my like purse like
when i like sex for like with someone i
care about that i really like like it's
just
organic and it sucks but i also kind of
you're open to whatever it's just
organically happening yeah
like okay now we're going to come over
here and i have this weird mentality
where i think i kind of look at sex on
some level as like an endurance sport
where i'm like like i want to like push
like to me that stuff isn't necessarily
sexy it's just cool
it's like weird it's funny it's fun like
it's just cool
you know i don't necessarily think of it
as like hot
if that makes anything that makes sense
yeah
so what like
if you're taking a fist then a dick's
got to be all right then
uh some of those dicks are the size of
your arm there's no doubt
yeah i've seen those girls to put it up
next to their face and i'm like oh my
god or their arm and i'm like oh my god
right like i i mean everything stretches
but yeah like especially like in my
[ __ ] like i
don't have like i have a very shallow
vagina that's part of why i like anal
especially like in porn
because it's a it's easier it doesn't
you're not like hitting my cervix
um but like yeah whenever i talk to
people especially like in regular life
like
dude six to seven inches is fine like
that stuff that 14
13 12 inches [ __ ] like that's cool on
camera i don't want to do that on a
tuesday every day yeah
no i like because whenever i bring that
guy up people are like oh my god imagine
having a dick like that i'm like yeah
imagine you think you're like gonna have
a girlfriend who's gonna [ __ ] you
multiple times a week like do you that's
not gonna happen
yeah i bet it though yeah like that's
probably why they get important it's the
only time they can probably really get
laid consistently yeah
like a guy with that dick yeah
jesus christ you're blowing my mind over
here
um okay god you've done so much
um what
what made you retire what made you
finally say all right because you say
you
your first anal scene got cancelled you
said the first one the very first one
that i did yeah but you've done
other ones uh so i had done it in my
personal life but i hadn't done it on
camera
until last year um one were the five
ana buck guys that was like this uh that
was in
i think that was in like november
october of last year
i did my first anal on camera in it
ended up being in june of last year
june 2019. so i had already been
shooting for like a year
i waited to do it um because it's just a
way to like
pull out your career a little bit longer
um and i also like i sold mine for like
a premium
which is kind of sold your butthole for
my butthole for a premium you know you
got to get what it's for it's not no
you're
considered a virgin in porn like an anal
virgin or no
no by the way and tell them you've never
had anal sex no i've never
i've never lied about it whenever they
do the on-camera interviews with me and
it's like this where
they're like oh what's the craziest
thing you've ever done i'm like well
i fisted my girlfriend in the back of a
camaro there's been times where they're
like you can't say that
it's like they're gonna they're gonna
freak out um
but like no just because no one's seen
it yet like it's not available on the
internet
um so i had had it booked
um in like april of last year
and it took ages like i'd gone to my
agent in january been like i want to do
this so we were working on selling it to
this one company
it took months and months and months
they finally called me back for a go see
and then they booked it so i'm like
really stoked and uh it's like a month
out
and at the same time i had done a
podcast for i'd started doing podcasts
and um i did one for a guy that does a
show at the comedy store
up in the belly room and he knew that i
was doing improv at second city already
and he knew i wanted to do stand-up and
we wrapped up and he was like hey you're
really funny and if you want you can
write five minutes
and you can open my show and i was like
yes i would love to that'd be great
so cut to the show was saturday night
and then my anal scene sorry my anal
scene got booked right afterwards after
i had said i would do the show and it
gets booked for sunday right after the
show
so i have to call him and be like hey i
can't do this um
there's no way that i can do an anal
scene after being out till like three
o'clock in the morning eating fried
chicken at mills it's not gonna happen
thank you yeah what i was getting at
earlier and uh
he's like okay you know whatever so i'm
bummed whatever and then cut to
thursday right before this i get a call
from my agent but you so you canceled
the stand-up
cancelled i canceled the stand-up i was
like i can't because i gotta do this
anal you gotta do this this is my rent
money
you know thursday before i get a call
from my agent
the director saw my picture and he
didn't
like my face and didn't think i was
pretty enough
to be on his site [ __ ] you dude i know
i feel like my face was maybe not the
focal point of that movie
but like i don't split hairs or anything
here
um so i'm like living like i run around
my house screaming for like 45 minutes
and when i finally calm down i'm like
okay you know what do we do so i call my
buddy back i was like hey can i still do
your show at the comedy store and he
goes yeah of course so i have
at that point 24 hours to learn how to
write stand-up
and go open for jamie kennedy at the
comedy store on saturday night
so i googled how to write stand-up which
was very helpful actually
and uh i'm just writing writing writing
i drank a bottle of wine
i called my mom which i never do um
and was like crying i was like so
nervous i drink a pot of coffee like
even it out like get in the car
on my way and i'm coming in from the
valley because i lived in reseda i
i did my set to that uber driver like
five times
oh yeah i mean listen to it over and
over i was like do you think this is
good does this work
like holding this like crumpled piece of
paper just like shaking like trying to
like drink this coffee
and uh i was so nervous so i'm gonna ask
you this and i think i know the answer
more nervous the first time you did porn
or stand up oh stand up yeah i had a
feeling you were gonna say that oh way
more and then i'm like sitting in the
green room and like my buddy's like hey
you can't tell anyone you've never done
this before
so just be cool and i was like yeah
because that's really what's happening
here i'm not like sweating through my
jacket
um but i went up and it went really
really well and they had me on that show
for another like six months it was great
that's nice yeah and i've been there
ever since and it's been awesome but
yeah it was just the craziest like
world what like crazy i think that's the
craziest 24 hours i've ever been through
despite all this crazy stuff that
was just the pressure of that was insane
so what made you officially retire like
what was the last thing you did and
why did you get out all together uh
coved honestly
i i shot a scene on like march 13th
i think was my last scene um and i went
in to go
like quarantine or walk down and
i thought it i mean everyone thought it
was gonna be like two weeks right so i
was like all right whatever two weeks
not a big deal and then it
wasn't and my birthday was in april i
turned 26
and i was like okay like this is an
ending
by the time it does go back to normal
and we're like shooting again i might be
27
i don't want to get my tits done um and
uh
i kind of was just i things had been
picking up like as far as like stand up
and stuff i just i had just started like
to go on the road like right before this
all started
and so i was like you know it's just
time it felt like time for a new
adventure i'd done what i wanted to do i
had a really great time and a lot of
fun and it was just time to try
something new so
if it wasn't for cover would you still
be doing it i probably would have my
idea
in my head for this year was that i was
going to start phasing it out and
would be pickier and pickier work less
and less do some
because i don't want to slam the door
i'm not someone that's going to be like
mia khalifa and be like i never did this
don't talk about it
don't is that where she i know she like
got out of it and doesn't want to
be like be associated like i don't care
it's on the internet it's not going to
go away like i'm not an idiot so
um yeah i mean my idea was to phase it
out kovid just sped things up for me so
you know i'm lucky that right now we can
do everything online like with only fans
and stuff so i've still had like stable
income
um that's really nice especially trying
to pursue like a creative
career in la where you can just have
this kind of passive income is
super nice would you go back to it um
i don't think so are there any other
porn stars that
outside the guys like i know ron jeremy
there was a couple other guys that
dabbled but
uh are there any girls that porn stars
that have done stand up
yeah there's a couple um alexis fox does
it she's very funny she's been on
ymh um and she's a podcast yeah there's
there's a couple and there's a few that
kind of there's a bunch for a while
everybody was getting into djing
like all the porn girls were dj there
was there was a time when a bunch of
them were doing stand-up
um so i definitely kind of made the jump
to just being like
because i i liked porn and it was fun
but it was fun because it fit
my personality and my lifestyle and it
also like i was saying earlier
when i was like peak working in la doing
studio porn i only had to work
three days a month to pay all my bills
that's
yeah so i had all of this time to like
write and
and figure out what i wanted to do i'd
always wanted to be a writer when i was
little
and so a huge part of getting into bdsm
and porn and stand-up and everything was
that like i wanted to have a life that
was worth
writing about and it was interesting um
and so i kind of
after i'd had that breakdown like after
college and figured i didn't want to be
a
secretary at an accounting company um i
figured i would just go spend my
twenties
having adventures and figuring it out
and i've got to do that and that's like
i feel really lucky to have gotten to do
that
that's great yeah all right so i'm going
to ask you about advice to your 16 year
old self but before i do
i want to talk about this because you
said you um
you got stood up for the prom i did
isn't that right i did
tell me about that because i asked you
i'll bet you all the high school guys
now
so let's talk about that yeah it was my
senior prom
and i didn't think i was gonna get asked
i was not i hung out with
uh a lot of guys in high school it was
kind of a bro
like i wasn't i wasn't like the girl
everyone was having a crush on for sure
i was kind of like their buddy
and um this guy nick asked me and i was
really excited and i went to get a dress
and then
once again i think it was like wednesday
or thursday right before
and he calls me and he's like so um i
actually have this girlfriend emily and
i'm going to take her to the prom
instead no way
dropped you for another girl not just
stood you up that he was
already dating when he asked me in the
past dude smoked a lot of weed so like
he now
sells used couches in denver so i feel
like i did win
people lost the battle won the war
that's cool um but yeah i mean i was
devastated my little sister's in the car
i'm like crying i'm so upset and then um
this guy that i had gone to like
kindergarten with i'd gone to school
with him the whole time
calls me like a few hours later and he's
like hey i heard what happened that's
really shitty
we have all the same friends do you want
to go with me we'll have a great [ __ ]
time
and he did he saved the day he wore this
ridiculous white tux we had a blast he's
a korean and he's like two inches
shorter than me so my pictures were
great it was
so fun good guy joey all right joe um
but yeah i mean i wasn't like i was not
the sexy like bombshell hot girl at my
high school at all
um but when did the guys start finding
out that you did porn
mostly not till like this year and
none of them like contacted me about it
you say they followed you
they all followed me like a bunch and i
started seeing them like and i was like
hey did we
we went to high school today like on
instagram are they one of your only fans
as well
i think a couple of them actually i just
got a
custom video request from a boy that i
guess they did go to high school with
who apparently had a
huge crush on me in high school i don't
even remember this person like i don't
remember him
are you gonna give him a video he bought
a video i mean he paid me like a couple
hundred dollars but he was like do you
still have like this
he remembered this like hoodie that i
used to wear
i was like i can't believe it dude i
can't even remember i was like it's who
okay um all right hi i know there are
definitely people i don't remember from
high school either yeah
you were going through so much [ __ ] back
then like i can't remember
everybody totally and yeah you like have
your little group of friends and you're
not
yeah also you're just so every everyone
in high school is self-absorbed you just
are
it's being a teenager well now i do want
to ask you
after everything that we've heard today
here we've heard
quite a bit what advice would you go
back
and give your 16 year old self
uh don't go to college yet
um you will i don't regret going to
college
but i definitely i mean i don't do
anything with my art history degree
so um i would say that you know it gets
it's gonna get so awesome i actually had
this conversation with one of my really
good girlfriends the other day
where because she just got a really
kick-ass job like working at warner
brothers and um
we were talking about like if you could
go back and tell yourself and it was
just that like hey
we live in hollywood you know we get to
know these like incredible people and do
these amazing things and like your life
is going to get
so awesome because i grew up in like a
small town i didn't fit in
i didn't feel like i belonged anywhere
i didn't know i i just remember i was a
very lonely kid
and now i look at my life and i'm like
holy [ __ ] like this
is i've always tried to live my life in
a way that like my 15 year old self
would think i was really awesome
which like i would she would
i mean i also don't wake up till noon
like ever um
but uh yeah i just that it's gonna get
so great
that's awesome well thank you for coming
on here and being
literally so goddamn open um will you
please plug whatever you'd like again
yeah thank you um i would love to come
at any time this was really fun uh
you can follow me on twitter at the og
kennedy you can follow me on instagram
the underscore og kennedy my only fans
at the og kennedy.com
um you can listen to my podcast the
kennedy assassination it's been on
hiatus but it will be back
a week from today on next friday
and i'm really excited about that so
yeah and come out and see my show in
long beach on
halloween if uh you're no you're not
doing anything
because it's kovid so come out and see
my show in long beach
you can get the info for that on my
instagram or twitter all right
well thank you again this has been quite
interesting
for real i have enjoyed it um and as
always ryan sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media and
we'll talk to you all next week
[Applause]
[Music]
you